the gyro can experience this is what
those debates are like it's a condensed
version that's right of a conversation
and you also have an actual physical
time limit like you have a lot of
seconds to respond and then and then
they start talking over you I know time
is up excuse me mr. senator mr. senator
your time's up mr. senator okay I know
you [ __ ] it's no weights it's no way to
really understand people and you have to
be a forceful moderator but then when
you are a forceful moderator you like
injecting yourself into this
conversation yeah America doesn't want
that's good way to people for people to
hate you it's why people hate you
everyone's gonna hate your guts
yeah it's it's one of those weird
ancient holdovers from the past that is
wholly and completely unnecessary and in
fact probably kind of [ __ ] dangerous
because you're you're you don't ever get
a chance to see what a person is
actually like you just give us a chance
to see their show well you listen Donald
Trump show like Donald Trump a show I'd
lock you up you'd be in jail like that
kind of [ __ ] right everybody cheers
roars that's a show it's who's best at
television right right right
and he's a [ __ ] television guy he's a
television star than those clowns a star
yes it was like watching when he came
through and was debating against the
Republicans in the in that run-up to in
in all those debates he got up there
like a comedian
he was like I'm gonna talk about I'm in
the moment yes I'm gonna call everything
out I'm not gonna play this BS of all
your little etiquette that you've got
going on and he it he was a star he was
a stray knows how to work it so till
does this Biden thing that he's doing
now he's constantly making front Abidin
call him sleepy Joe Biden and he shows
like some misquote that Biden said does
anybody something about what we're here
for the facts not the truth or something
like that what is the crazy Biden quote
that he had that everybody's been making
fun of listen this I say stupid [ __ ] all
the time
everybody does who talks a lot but they
talk a lot you're gonna jumble your
words together I do it all the time of
course but if you've run it for
president man they find something like
that
jumble here a jumble there you better be
ready to defend yourself that's right
but that's the thing you someone has to
act the way he acts exactly you've got
to be in the moment you got a call
things I could be honest gonna be a
comma you got to be a comic ya trumpet
when he was running he reminded me of
like the comics from Long Island big
loud insult comics Biden tells on words
we choose truth over facts what uh was I
mean mighty wrote that truth over fat
I'd like to see what he said how he said
it
how did he say it yeah cuz he might have
been like we truth suit truth choose
truth over facts and that's not good
time to get up everybody knows who
Donald Trump is even as supporters know
who he is we got to let him know who we
are we choose unity over division we
choose science over fiction we choose
truth over facts and so folks if you're
interested join me
look we all mess up a line here in the
seems like a remote control with a
shitty battery you know that one it's
kinda getting the volume but not quite
high change the channel you gotta move
it around bro he's got so little juice
left in the tank I know Donald Trump
will chew him up unless he gets a good
doctor you need a good doctor he's get
on steroids immediately
don't you think trying to take something
for sure yeah you can't be that age and
not be able you got to take something oh
he's got billions of dollars why
wouldn't he take something course he's
supposedly he has been on some storm of
and feta mean prescribed by a doctor in
the past I was like this that gives me
the sniffles that's why say me all the
time but that he also have a cold
I mean he's [ __ ] 80 years old he's
the president knighted States I'm sure a
fairly stressful job
yeah but he there was a journalist that
was claiming that he had some sort of
diet pill prescription and brought up
the very pharmacy where you got it
fulfilled right who know if it's true
who knows if it's true
[Applause]